Carmelo Lombardo has managed this
seafood shop in Sydney for three decades
and is used to seeing thousands of
people pass through its doors each week
now there's only a handful and he's had
to adapt to survive the business is
still open but most of its sales are
taking place online instead with staff
delivering produce to homes those casual
staff that we used to utilize in in a in
the retail shop we've then moved them
around to suit the online other
businesses in the Sydney fish market
aren't so lucky
some have closed others have seen
revenues drop by up to 80% within our
retail tendencies certainly there's been
stand downs and other job losses which
is really unfortunate Australia isn't in
lockdown but strict social distancing
measures main shopping strips remain for
the most part empty with doors shut and
many out of work but keeping people at
home seems to be working
despite some outbreaks Australia's
infection rate has slowed recording
fewer than 100 new cases a day well down
from weeks ago and it's had a relatively
low death rate with the economic costs
rising business groups are pushing for
restrictions to start being lifted and
there are petitions from local people
who want to return to beaches any
prospect of lifting restrictions is a
delicate balance for the government at
this stage it says it's too early to
ease any social distancing measures
worried that it could lead to a second
wave of cases similar to other countries
like Singapore and Japan infectious
disease experts agree but if
restrictions were to be lifted they say
it would have to happen slowly with
international borders remaining closed
for some time start to lift some of the
restrictions locally until that happens
businesses are navigating a new normal
as the government works on how and when
life can return to what it was before
the crisis Nikola gage al Jazeera Sydney